but i want to talk about so i want to
bring it back closer to home with what's
happening because you know we can talk
about potential for war and the crisis i
want i want to pull up this story
from reuters world food prices hit 10
year peak from the food and agricultural
organization which is based out of rome
they say that uh this is the u.n
actually it's a u.n agency saying it
fao's food price index which tracks
international prices of mostly global
traded food commodities averaged 130
points last month the highest reading
since september 2011 according to the
agency's data and check this out
america's bare shelves walmart and
costco limit toilet paper sales while
toy companies warn parents their kids
christmas gifts won't arrive in time
thanks to backlog at ports rail yards
and on the roads
supply chain problems that have been
tormenting retailers for months are
showing up in america's in america
stores around the countries around the
country there are shortages of goods on
shelves in target costco home depot and
sears they're saying that the cost of
shipping from china to la is now at
twenty thousand dollars four times what
it cost last october and i think it's
like ten times as high as it is as it
normally is supposed to be
what do you think this means for people
in america i think you know we talk
about the people who can stand up who
can reject the mandates and i think we
talk about this foreign conflict but it
all comes back to whether or not
someone's going to be able to have food
on their plate
complying won't get you there ignoring
what's happening around the world won't
get you there
i mean this may be one of the hardest
times for a lot of people we we've gone
through this golden age where people
have lived so peacefully so perfectly
with movies with pizza man you pick up
your phone you go pizza and then boom a
pizza shows up you can actually pick up
your phone today press the button and
say order me a pizza and then it'll find
you a restaurant you can get it now all
of a sudden we're being told our
supplies are being strained our food
prices are through the roof
hard to find some supplies people are
now having to experience what actual
survival and hardship is going to be and
there's war on the around the horizon
yeah if people get their act together
man start standing up standing up for
themselves being responsible we talk
about that's part of the problem i'm
sorry sorry i mean um we we talk about
hard times i don't think anyone's
actually thought through what a hard
time is going to look like and i think
we're starting to see that just from so
this is really simple something really
small and something that i noticed was
that there's less selection on the store
shelves like why don't we have 600 types
of peanut butter to choose from anymore
because we just don't have that anymore
so it's starting small and it's gonna
get really bad because they're so backed
up like off the coast of california
we're talking about how the shipping
ships the crate ships whatever they're
called cargo ships cargo ships there you
go are all backed up and there's like
hundreds of thousands of packages on
there like you're talking about
christmas being delayed and all this
other stuff these are the hard times
coming like i don't there's no way to
avoid it well i guess it means strong
men are coming after that right that's
right that's my thinking we've just been
so conditioned to be comfortable
conditioned to be comfortable we're also
extremely spoiled and i i i kind of
recognized this and i bet you did too
tim after traveling a lot going around
the world i mean i was in zimbabwe i was
in venezuela you were in venezuela as
well when you stay with people when you
live with people and when you see world
the world from an international kind of
perspective from a third world
perspective it really gives you a lot of
uh a feeling of humbleness especially
when you come back here and you have so
much abundance and you have so much
options and and us being spoiled is only
going to add to the disaster of what's
coming because there's also going to be
a lot of fears about panic buying
there's also going to be a lot of people
who are unprepared for this there's
going to be a lot of uh latte drinking
flip-flop wearing yuppies who are going
to try to tweet their way out of this
problem and there's no way of hitting
the computer keyboard to help you in a
situation where resources become very
hard to get so so there's going to be a
big reality check for a lot of
individuals to see how useful they are
to see the skills that they have to see
what they could do
and it's really going to lead to a very
transitionary time that i think we're
starting to begin to head into right now
i was just thinking about you know we've
talked about people in cities being
unable to survive in the end of like a
serious catastrophe and then you know
luke mentioning these hippie flip-flop
latte drinking guys and i'm just sitting
here imagining
this is the first my third my first
thought was well i'm good you know i got
we got chickens in a garden and we're
building more and we're going to be a
little bit more responsible in the
middle of nowhere in the middle of
nowhere yeah and then i'm like what
would they do and i'm thinking like well
they might start attacking each other
stealing each other's food what happens
when they don't have anything what
happens when they can't even you know
there's no people left in the cities and
then they're all fleeing and then i'm
imagining like coming outside one day i
feel like it's like two in the morning
and here at rustling and then you know
it's like someone here is like tim i
think there's an animal outside and you
know we grab the 410 and we go outside
and we're like looking around with the
light on and then all of a sudden we see
some like scraggly looking hipster
wearing a flannel shirt
and he's like he's grabbed my chicken
and i caught him in the lights and i'm
like hey you hippie hipster give me that
chicken back and he's like and then he
runs
yeah
but it is it is funny to think but i'm
like that's like a real possibility
these people who don't know how to
survive what are they gonna do they're
gonna have to look if it ever came down
to the point where the cities didn't
function properly it's very difficult to
get food and resources into cities right
and if we're talking about oil prices
through the roof if we're talking about
global elites that are like people
shouldn't be driving then these people
in the cities who've never grown a
vegetable in their life and i'm not
saying everyone in a city's never done
that people have gardens but i'm saying
the ones who didn't the true
hipster woke you know socialist types
they're they're not just going to roll
over they're going to start screaming
and pounding on walls and then one day
you out in west virginia are going to
see to the to your shock a hipster
wearing like some kind of expensive
clothes they got a thrift store that was
like you know for some reason sure
grabbing your chicken and running and
like what are they gonna do with that
thing but hey man i would not be
surprised if like in five years you see
things like that what about just like an
upper middle class you have like instead
of like some hippie you just have like a
mortgage broker trying to steal your
chickens you know what i mean like
really like folks like that a lot of
folks who don't really have the
wherewithal to like survive and like
fortunately you guys and a lot of folks
we know like you know we're a little
prepared when it comes that sort of
thing like you guys are out in the
middle of nowhere it's nice but
and that's something i always think
about too it's like man and here's why i
used to think about it for a while and
now i'm having second thoughts after all
the cove events was a lot of folks who
were like really well off or get to a
certain point it's like their bug out
location a ton of folks were buying
property in new zealand right right
mountain fortresses too yeah yeah i
think peter thiel like bought us bought
himself a passport and he's got a
compound out there and it's like hey you
know if the crap hits the fan like get
the fam get in the jet and off we go and
i can't blame them and it's great
because you think about it it's like
it's in the middle of nowhere it's very
hard to get to it has mild summers mild
winters tons of natural resources like i
spent like a month there it's amazing
and everywhere yeah exactly it's like
there's no natural predators and it has
which one is is they have like four
million people and i think it's like 30
million sheep and 50 million heads of
cattle
right out there and it's like it's like
lord of the rings it's gorgeous and it's
like you can go out there and pretty
much live off the land one way or
another and it's like that's a very safe
place but then with a lot you know some
of the restrictions and a little
authoritarian government i think you
could still hide out there pretty well
well in latin america your dollar goes a
long way that's true and a lot of latin
american police officers and politicians
really love getting tipped
they really love this we're talking
about when the dollar is is of course
yeah
and it's going to create a very very
unique interesting situation people in
the comment section are saying that
there's going to be soy seeking hordes
of people wandering about looking for
for uh you know soy soy uh but but
a lot of also very powerful people
bought a lot of property in latin
america um you know and a lot of people
are also looking into latin america
because the police officers there and
the and the law and and you know the
government there doesn't have the tools
to enforce a lot of the ridiculousness
as well you you brought up a mortgage
broker so to be more practical than
being like you know you hear rustling
you go outside there's a hipster like
eating one of your chickens and he's
like
no but i think what what by what might
be uh closer to reality is
you know you you live out you get a
homestead you move out maybe to like
central west virginia there's a lot of
farms out here and they're amazing
almost all the farms you can pull up and
you buy fresh foods we went to one place
they had like a trailer and they had
like we got tenderloins they were
amazing so what will happen is one day a
mortgage broker will walk up on your
property with a briefcase wearing a nice
little suit and you'll be like you know
what can i do your fur and i'll be like
i need to work the cities can't sustain
me they're you know what am i supposed
to do you know so i'm out here trying to
find a job i can do anything and then
you know this farmer is going to be like
what can you do what did you work i'm a
mortgage broker do you know how to you
know till a field no
do you know how to help tend to the
chickens no cows no
i don't think there's anything you can
do for me yeah maybe you can lift heavy
things we'll figure it out but then what
happens is when this guy gets rejected
he comes back in the middle of the night
and tries to steal because people are
not going to roll over they need to
survive yeah just like a desperate bear
will make desperate moves he's going to
be like hey i have these federal reserve
fiat notes i could give you do you do
you want them and i don't care if he has
millions of them if he can't have real
life skills to fix things build things
or make his
own way i'm not interested in working
with any of those people tim are you
going to be like the next rick grimes
you know from walking
he's like the dead but he's just one of
those things like he was like the leader
of a like he had a compound and they're
traveling and it's like all the stuff
you guys have described like sounds like
i have we have we have a caravan uh some
people
yeah yeah people in the comments section
are saying uh
uh soybeans instead of zombies
there's going to be a bunch of zoy bees
around running around so i mean it could
be like the walking dead but but again
that's kind of it's very entertaining to
talk about these kind of cultural issues
but when you kind of do look at south
africa the situation there has already
turned pretty bad yeah human beings are
very resilient they'll always find a way
that's why when you said people will
become hardened people will become
smarter people will become more in tuned
to the land i think there's also going
to be a lot of vast opportunities for
that where a lot of city dwellers are
going to return to farming
self-sustainable lifestyles um because
of necessity and i think that's going to
be a good thing right now most of our
farming is factory farming a lot of it
is monsanto a lot of his gmo a lot of it
is absolute bull crap a lot of it is
owned by bill gates to try to create
fake meat but but again when when things
fall down we're also going to understand
that the authorities won't be able to
hold things together and there's going
to be a free-for-all and uh you know
it's already it's already they can't
holding together when when we see these
stories about the federal government's
heavy hand
making you know statements about going
after parents
that's that's like a frightened bear
it's an animal trying to look bigger and
scare you it's the animal puffing up and
you know it's the blowfish
it's like okay i'll stay away from you
but yeah it's kind of it's kind of fake
authority too because like real
authority comes heavy and hard with
weapons they're trying to be nice this
is like the federal government's like
hey do we say but we're not gonna mess
with you but like a real authoritarian
government would be like gonna mow down
who disagrees and then everyone else do
what i say now thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time